the idea of arming teachers and staff to
prevent school violence he's not new
schools across the country thought about
it long before President Trump endorsed
the idea this week weber International
University in Florida announced
yesterday that it will allow select
faculty with extensive training to carry
concealed firearms 40 states have laws
against guns in K through 12 schools but
many of those states also let school
districts decide their own rules Niki
batiste visited a Colorado town where
the school board voted unanimously to
have some teachers carry guns Nicki good
morning good morning John Carl Donaldson
spent six years with the National Guard
he's now a science teacher at a rural
Colorado High School and volunteered to
carry a firearm in class he says it was
something he felt he had to do because
the nearest law enforcement office is
about 25 minutes away
I guess the really basic question a lot
of people are asking why should teachers
be armed teachers within the classroom
they're always the ones that are gonna
be the first to respond why not give
them something to fight back with to
fight back Carl Donaldson is armed with
a nine-millimeter Glock handgun where is
your firearm can I show it to you yes
please
and your cowboy boot so why wear boots
you didn't used to wear boots no is this
gun loaded there's nothing in the
chamber the school board would not allow
for us to put one in the chamber so it's
never loaded in class that's in the clip
would it be more effective to have a
loaded gun yes that's a concern
absolutely especially if they come after
me and they get him faster training they
teaches how to fight them off and then
get to your weapon
faster is a three day course that trains
teachers like Donaldson in firearms and
trauma response and includes a simulated
school shooting scenario I went through
the semi lated school shooting training
and my heart rate was up here do you
think in that split-second and the
worst-case scenario you could make the
decision and identify a shooter you know
that's the question you know do all the
training in the world I don't know if
you're gonna be able to perform when it
comes time so many schools across the
country are debating whether arming
teachers is the best way to keep
students safe we sat down with a few
other teachers here during their lunch
break having that same discussion I had
really mixed feelings when they first
came up with it
it was very saddening to me that that's
what this has come to and I think the
biggest thing that helped me with it was
knowing what the training was or would
be for the staff that were interested do
you think arming teachers is the right
response to these school shootings I
don't know if there is a right response
to be real honest I think it's at least
a step to hopefully help you know deter
our number one priority is the safety of
our children and this is a step
hopefully in the right direction
with armed staff do you feel safer do
you feel your students are safer I do I
do - I do
so too does School Superintendent Steve
McCracken our parents important that
some staffer armed yes they are and it's
posted at the front door or each
exterior door unfortunately there have
been a number of active shooters in
schools and and I hope that we're
prepared to respond if it does happen in
our school district maybe not right for
every school but it's right for us at
this point since last week's shooting in
parkland Florida creators of the faster
program say schools in 35 states have
inquired about training over the past
five years the program has trained about
1,300 school staff for more than 200
districts across a dozen states
I thought Carl's answer was very
interesting when you said are you ready
to use this and he said you don't really
know what you're gonna do when the time
comes you have the story right now in
Florida where you have the arm
profession we were talking about this
this morning well he didn't go rushing
in because he knew what he what he was
up against we expect teachers to do that
I think the big question is you know how
are they ready but he said look it's
better than nothing if I take out one
student at least I've saved 250 just so
much pressure to put on ginger so I
think so too
thank you very much Nicky very good to
see you